all technical reason why a woman can't
do with a circle what a man can do I
mean there's loads of reasons like it is
about the upper body strength it's about
like the way that the body is built
should women Surfers at the elite level
get the same as well like again I think
it's it just is different like it's a
different kind of game where people
watch it oh you're shaking your head no
I just think we'll just start making the
same amount of money as the man that we
should get paid the same I don't hear
the men whining about only fans models
getting paid more than nothing I don't
hear the men whining about models
getting paid more than them Kendall
Jenner is the highest paid supermodel
where are the male supermodels